all right another day of Muller mania
another day to talk about Muller and his
report I am so excited I'm so excited to
talk about this this issue is so
interesting I could just talk about it
all day it's the only thing I want to
talk about I have so so much
fascinating analysis to offer look
honestly part of me would rather jump in
front of a 16-wheeler then talk about
this damned issue for one more second
iiiiii in fact I went outside looking
for a 16-wheeler but I couldn't find one
so unfortunately for you so we will talk
about Muller and the hearing and
everything a little bit today because
news cycle is king you got to follow the
news cycles we'll talk about that then
we're gonna move on to two more
interesting things in my opinion but
first you know here's an important thing
your confidence is crucial and sometimes
one change can make all the difference
hair club knows that that's why they're
inviting you to become part of the hair
club family to see how getting the most
out of your hair can really change your
life on so you can make everything
different they understand the emotions
you're feeling when you start to lose
your hair and your whole look is
changing they know the questions you
have
that's because Hair Club is the leader
in total hair solutions with a legacy of
success for over 40 years whether you're
looking to revitalize the growth of your
own hair or learn more about the latest
methods of hair replacement or
restoration hair clubs experts and your
professionally trained analysts Eilis
hair health experts consultants they
will craft a personalized solution it's
no cookie cutter thing it's gonna be
personalized for you you know here's
what you can do here's what I would
recommend go to hair club comm slash
Walsh today and if you do that you're
gonna get a free hair analysis and a
free take home hair kit all valued at
over 300 bucks but you're getting it for
free
okay so again I emphasize that is a $300
value that you're getting for free if
you go to hair club comm slash Walsh
hair club comm slash Walsh experience
your hair and your life at its best
only with hair club I'm certain you'll
love the club
all right molar Robert molar was dragged
and I do think literally dragged from
the looks of it up to Capitol Hill for
hearings today it really seemed like you
didn't want to be there and I can see
why Democrats of course were expecting
fireworks I mean they're always
expecting fireworks especially where
Muller is concerned and he has let them
down so many times in the firework
department but yet they keep expecting
it they they just keep coming back all
of his fireworks end up just being the
little sparklers that burned for a
second and then and then dead of burning
your hand and you throw them out and
that's what it was again today
shockingly in fact as the hearing was
beginning and Muller gave his opening
statement he made it very clear that he
isn't going to say anything that wasn't
already in the report everything that he
says it's gonna be back it's gonna be in
the report if you ask him a question
that has to do with something outside of
the report he's not gonna answer it
everything's gonna go back to the report
which raises the question what's the
point of the hearing it's already in it
he wrote 400 pages
well somebody wrote 400 pages we don't
know if it's him we'll go back to that
in a second
but it's this 400 pages that's that's
all he's got to say and it's right there
you could read it for yourself yet we
had the hearing and why is that well
because of course the real point is for
grandstanding but but here's the great
great thing and this is what I
appreciate this this is the one thing I
enjoyed as I was suffering through
watching these hearings one thing I
enjoyed is that these politicians were
there hoping to grandstand
but their grandstanding was undermined
at every turn by the fact that Muller
apparently didn't bring his hearing aid
or he forgot to turn it on so we didn't
hear anything that they said so they
they they were they were trying to just
go over everything that was already in
there in fact Nadler Jerry Nadler was
the first person asked questions and his
whole line of questioning was just going
over what was already in the report but
Moeller couldn't hear what he was saying
so it was it was like that Jerry Nadler
was a mr. Muller
the report states X does it not I'm
sorry what was that
well it's in my reading of the report it
states X I'm can you repeat that one
last time X is in the report does it not
say X and so there was just like that
back and forth back and forth which was
pretty funny
but at the same time it was kind of
concerning because Robert Muller really
came across like frankly a befuddled and
confused old man which I'm not gonna
make fun of him for that he's 74 75
years old something like that and he
looked every bit his age and was acting
it too and that is no surprise I mean
you've 7475 you've been given this
high-pressure job it seemed like it wore
really wore him down I imagine that's
part of the reason why he didn't want to
do this hearing because he knew he
wouldn't perform well and he didn't
perform well but it is as I said
concerning because it makes you think
well who this was the guy that was doing
this whole investigation for two years
is this is this person even capable of
doing an investigation like this was he
the one actually running the
investigation is this his report and you
know not somebody else what we end up
with it then in the end is the report
that was already written and published a
long time ago we have a hearing about a
report with the guy who ostensibly wrote
it but has already said he won't provide
extra details about it and we have a guy
who wrote the report ostensibly who
can't hear and doesn't understand what's
going on apparently and doesn't even
know what's in his own report and that
all adds up to it did add up to maybe a
few humorous moments but other than that
as far as I can tell nothing of
consequence you know the Talking Heads
and the pundits are gonna parse it and
come up with things that are significant
and it's on both sides of it but really
when it comes down to it this Muller
thing it's all it's all baked in as far
as the voters are concerned if you hate
Trump then you believe that he's a
Russian spy and a traitor and nothing
Muller says is is gonna change your mind
it doesn't matter and if you support
Trump again it doesn't matter what
Muller says you support them and I think
if you're in the middle you prob
we are bored with this by now and are
sick of it and you're gonna make your
decision about who you vote for based on
something other than Robert Muller
that's that's my feeling anyway so none
of this matters
that's my analysis and I will move on
let's move to something that I think
does matter this week and I want to I
want to go check in with this story
again because the media wants to move on
the media has moved on the left has
moved on but I don't think we should
move on just yet Erika Thomas you may
remember her if you can think back all
the way back to the distant past of this
past weekend you'll remember that Erika
Thomas is the Georgia Democrat who
claimed that she was verbally assaulted
by a racist white man at the grocery
store she claimed that she was in the
express lane with too many items which
in my view already puts her in the wrong
no matter what happens next she's in the
wrong because she's in the she's abusing
the express lane which is one of the
worst things a human being can do but
she claims she was in the express lane
racist white guy comes in raving lunatic
apparently starts screaming at her go
back where you came from even though
that doesn't make sense in the context
of this dispute she records the tearful
Facebook video and is so upset about it
traumatized
well the story begins to fall apart
immediately we talked about it on Monday
because first of all it was just
patently unbelievable from the very
start second when the supposed racist
who it turns out as a Cuban Democrat
shows up on camera to confront her and
dispute her version of events she she
starts backtracking and hedging
immediately and says I well maybe he
didn't say go back where you came from
but he said something that's in that
general vicinity of statements now
though it's gotten worse because
witnesses are coming forward and their
security camera footage which police
have looked at because oh yeah the
police got involved the police actually
did an investigation for some reason I
mean even if Erika Thomas was not a God
forsaken liar which she is but even if
she was telling the truth and this
really did happen
as she says why would the police be
involved what's the crime you know to
say go back where you came from it may
be a jerky thing to say but it's not
illegal it's not an illegal statement
yet the police did get involved and they
announced yesterday that no charges are
going to be filed unsurprisingly but
they also have now a police report which
includes their interviews of witnesses
and those interviews do not at all back
up what Erika Thomas said which shows
again just how stupid these race hoaxers
tend to be I mean Jesse Smollett so many
things about that story it was bound he
was bound to be exposed as a as a hoaxer
he went about it in the dumbest possible
way and what I said about that is look
if your justice Millette
and you want to do a race hoax and you
want to pretend that you were beat up by
white guys shouting this is Magga
country then your best bet now I would
recommend not making up the story to
begin with but if you're gonna make up
the story then just make up the story
don't get into don't be too specific
don't hire two of your friends to
pretend to be white guys don't involve
other people potential witnesses just
say hey this happened and if you're not
specific about it and you don't involve
the police that nobody's ever gonna be
able to prove it didn't happen it's the
same thing here you you you're basing
your lie on an incident that actually
did happen which means there are
witnesses and then you get the police
involved and it's just it's it's you're
bound to be exposed as a liar so Erika
Thomas what she could have done is just
she could have done her tearful video
that it was it and and completely
invented the story you know don't
specify what grocery store it occurred
in don't involve the police and nobody
will ever be able to prove it didn't
happen because there are no witnesses to
interview there's no security camera
footage to look at and at least you
could always pretend that it
did happen and no one can prove
otherwise but she is on top of a liar
apparently a very stupid person so the
the Atlanta journal-constitution has a
report based on the police report and
listen I'll read the first two
paragraphs from that article this is
interesting it says a witness to a
heated grocery store encounter between
state representative Erika Thomas and a
man she accused of uttering racist
comments told authorities she didn't
hear him make any make those remarks
according to a Cobb County police report
a Publix employee told a Cobb County
officer that she witnessed part of the
conversation and heard Thomas
continuously tell Eric sparks to go back
where you came from but did not hear
sparks utter those words to Thomas so
not only did she make that she was
according to this witness she was the
one who said go back where you came from
that is that is in curtain now that's a
twist I didn't expect I knew she made up
that you know that the fact that he said
it was made up I could tell that
immediately but I didn't expect that she
was actually the one who said it the
police report says that they the you
know the police looked at the security
camera footage if there's no audio to it
but in the footage it's Thomas who's the
aggressor she's going up to sparks
wagging her finger in his face he's
backing away and then another witness
said that he started leaving and she
kept coming at him and was yelling at
him so there you go no witnesses back up
Thomas's account one witness says that
Thomas is the one who said the racist
stuff so then it appears that Thomas was
the aggressor Thomas then allegedly
would be the racist Thomas is a lying
fraud shocker of shockers but what's
happened to the story then over the
weekend when she first recorded her
tearful video with some very bad acting
I might add it was all over the place
media was on top of it
Democrats were talking about it it's
Trump's fault Trump's America it's an
epidemic it's terrible hashtag I stand
with Erika Thomas trending on Twitter
and then it's
to fall apart and the story just just
disappears
even though because you could try to say
well okay well it didn't happen so it's
not a story then it didn't happen so
what are we talking about well no
actually it's a bigger story now that it
didn't happen if it did happen as Erika
Thomas said then it's not a story the
fact that it didn't happen is a story
that is the story because think about it
if it actually happened as Erika Thomas
said well then what what's the story the
story is some nobody some stranger some
jerk yelled at somebody in line at a
grocery store that that happens every
day it's not a story it doesn't matter
but an elected official making up a
story slandering a constituent trying to
stoke racial tensions for her own gain
that's a story okay that's important
that's relevant that's something that is
of public interest yet the media only
cares about the irrelevant version of
the story the false version now that the
truth has come out they flee and that's
what happens you know with reporters is
that the minute the truth is there there
the truth is here let's get out of here
and they run away and you know what the
really sad thing is here's the really
sad thing is that Thomas is going to
suffer no consequences for this there
will be no consequences for her because
I think a lot of people on the Left
they're gonna continue believing her
version even though it's been pretty
much conclusively debunked now they're
gonna believe her version just like
there are there are liberals who still
go around talking about hands up don't
shoot even though that narrative has
been absolutely conclusively debunked
they still stick with it all these years
later so I think that there gonna be
some people on the left some Democrat
voters who just decide to believe it
even though it's obviously not true and
then they're gonna be even more who
maybe know that it's not true and
acknowledge it but don't care because on
the Left what we have to understand is
that the truth doesn't matter to these
people they don't care about that they
really don't what they care about is the
narrative they
you know winning politically and winning
ideologically that's what they care
about and they believe that the truth is
sort of an irrelevant detail and that
ends justify the means and so if if you
need to bend the truth or lie for your
you know for the greater cause then
that's okay to do they're perfectly fine
with that because what they believe is
America is a racist country where these
kinds of things happen all the time so
even if this specific thing didn't
happen these kinds of things happen so
it's still legitimate and she's calling
attention to the sort of thing that
happens even if it's not this particular
thing that's the way they're going to
rationalize it which means that if
anything that's probably helped her I
think that it got our name out there it
it increased her profile and it
increased her street cred among among
Democrat voters whether they believe it
or not and so I say the Erika Thomas is
very stupid maybe she's not you know
maybe she knew that yeah this is a this
is an unbelievable story and it and the
truth is going to come out and it will
be debunked but it's still going to help
me with with the suckers who make up my
voting base it's going to help me
alright so here's this is fun
bella thorne is I guess an actress or
something bella thorne is a she's a I
think an actress singer something or
anyway she's she I guess she's famous
and she was interviewed by ABC News for
reasons that after watching the
interview still escaped me but during
the course of the interview she made a
huge announcement that I think is is you
want to talk about newsworthy this is
newsworthy stuff watch this in the past
she's used Twitter to casually come out
as bisexual but today she's expanded her
sexual orientation I'm actually a
pansexual I didn't know that okay
somebody somebody explained to me so
thoroughly what that is explain that to
me you like beings you like what you
like doesn't have to be a girl or a guy
or you know he is she a day or this or
that it's literally you like personality
like you just like a being first of all
I have to say that I love that every
other show of this type is gonna be
playing clips from the from the Moller
hearing today for their show but I'm
playing clips of Bella Thorne
talking about her pansexuality you know
that's that's the difference between me
and the rest of them second I love that
that she said this and the woman
interviewing her had to pretend to take
it seriously it was it was so awkward
where she said actually I'm pansexual oh
okay well that's nice it reminds me of
the time when uh when I first told my
parents I was gonna become a
professional blogger was this a Oh a
blogger like for a job is that okay well
that that that that'll be interesting so
Bella Thorne is pansexual she says which
she says that means she's attracted to
beings beings she's attracted to beings
now if pansexual means anything other
than bisexual which she says that it
does she says I well I thought it was
bisexual but I'm actually pants I'm
attracted to beings in general but if
that's the case then um then it would
have to mean you know you're attracted
to beings
well beings include literally any living
entity at all
a moose a cricket a lobster three toed
sloth a fox an aardvark
I mean Noah's Ark basically Noah's
entire Ark that's Yumi be attracted to
everything bella thorne would go crazy
in Noah's Ark she'd be attracted to
everything man woman child animal Jenny
because that's if you're telling me
you're pansexual your sexuality knows no
boundaries whatsoever any being is
potentially an object of your sexual
attraction that's what you're saying I
mean that's that is the that's the
implication but if Bella is not in fact
attracted to insects and reptiles and
mammalian forest creatures
and her attraction is in fact limited to
adult males and females well then we're
back to bisexual so it is a is it's a
pansexual then is a category that
doesn't need to exist and doesn't exist
and I'm just gonna spoiler alert here no
Bella thought and I know this is gonna
sound very presumption something Bella
Thorne you say you're pansexual you're
not actually you actually are not I know
I know it's I am now mansplaining your
own sexuality to you I am doing that you
are not pansexual because I am pretty
sure you are not potentially attracted
to any being in existence like I'm
pretty sure there are limits okay if you
go to the zoo okay that I am pretty sure
that for you is not a sexual expedition
I mean you are you're looking at the
Polar Bear cage you like right you're
gonna rule out polar bears as a object
then you're not paying sexual you're
that's bisexual that's already a thing
we don't need a term of this term over
here doesn't mean anything
you're not that nobody is that that
doesn't exist which is good you know it
did that's good that means we because
that would be of it would be impossible
to function as a human if you could
potentially be sexually attracted to any
being the only way to make it broader
and I mean if you really want to be
progressive then rather than being
attracted to beings because here's the
thing when you're attracted to beings
you are still discriminating because
then you're saying that well you are
limiting it at least to living creatures
now if you really want to be because of
you'll say that I'm attracted to any
entity of any kind it could be it could
be a dog could be a woman could be a man
could be a door you know could be a lamp
any this desk right here who knows
that's that's progressive right you want
to be really you burp and sexual you
should be attracted to anything anything
literally anything the color blue I mean
anything I guess the color blue isn't an
entity though
all right I have to talk about this for
a minute also before we get the emails
because this is hilarious this got a
literal lol out of me last night when I
read it this story last night well as
the story went last night before the
full story came out as it tends to do
the story was that forever21 the women's
clothing store was sending Atkins diet
bars with all of its plus-sized clothing
orders if you ordered a plus-size if you
ordered plus size clothes online as the
story went forever21 would send you a
diet bar with the package which is great
I mean that is that is just hysterical
that's even funnier than Bella Thorne be
contracted to grasshoppers I mean you
know you we are doomed as a society if
we cannot all agree that that is
hilarious
you know I don't care if you if you're
overweight yourself you have to admit
you know if you order like if I ordered
size 52 jeans from from somewhere and
they said it was a diet bar in I would
crack up laughing it would be great but
of course in our humorless society this
is a source of outrage hurt feelings
trauma oh my gosh it's fat shaming it's
the Macy's plates all over again I'm
having nightmares I'm having flashbacks
which even if it is fat shaming first of
all it's free food which why are you
could plot why would anyone complain
about that especially someone who's
plus-sized now I'm kidding that was I'm
sorry that was it was a joke I didn't
mean it don't there was not a fat joke
it wasn't my point is simply that if
you're you know a why would you complain
about free food right I mean we all like
food especially you know I'm kidding
that's not what I meant
I don't mean that it's not it's I'm not
I'm not trying to make light of this I
mean I couldn't make light of that
anyway no that's not ii here's a point
just scratch all that it's just it's
funny it's only point I'm making ok I'm
not making as it turns out though of
course this is Hall this this is all
taken out of context it turns out that
forever 21 was sending Atkin bar Atkins
bars with every order of any size any
product and so this is just now as a
marketing strategy that is pretty stupid
because you you have to figure you're
putting diet bars in with it like people
are gonna order plus-sized clothing and
you're putting diet bars in there and
and you must know how our society is
like how did you not know and that this
is what doesn't offend me in the least
like I said I think it's hilarious but
probably forever21 they weren't going
for hilarious and it always shocks me
when you discover that people who work
in marketing departments for these big
companies nationwide successful
companies it shocks me when they have no
understanding of how our culture works
how did you get that job you know in a
marketing department your whole job is
to know how our culture works and and
how to appeal to people and how did you
not any how is it that we think they had
to sit down and have this conversation
and say hey you know we should send
something free with all the orders and
you know what should we send and someone
had to suggest a we could send a dive
bars yeah that'd be a good idea how did
no one else in the room say hey hold on
a second you know overweight people
they're gonna be ordering clothes we're
gonna get the diet part they're gonna
take it the wrong way it's gonna end up
on Twitter I'm telling you guys mate how
did nobody say that all right
anyway funny stuff good stuff there
let's let's go to emails couple of
interesting emails this is from Kristin
Matt Walsh Oh at gmail.com
Matt will show Jamila commas email
address this is from Kristin says hi
Matt I recently have been going through
a mini crisis of faith I won't call it a
full-blown crisis as I'm not questioning
say the infallibility of the Bible or
the basic tenets of the Christian faith
but I've started to question certain
doctrines I grew up with that I always
accepted as biblical but now I'm not so
sure for instance when I was a child
I've been taught that once saved always
saved or that you can't lose your
salvation but now I'm coming across
passages that seem to contradict that
idea such as Hebrews 6
four through six and first Timothy for
chapter four verse one more recently my
husband and I attended a so-called
Reformed Church that basically held a
Calvinist doctrine the ideas of limited
atonement and unconditional elections on
an ended consistent on their faith face
but when taken to their logical
conclusions I found them abhorrent I
would ask seemingly reasonable questions
like why would a loving God predestined
some people for eternal salvation and
others for eternal down damnation before
the dawn of time only only to be
directed to Roman's 9 and to be told
that I couldn't ask those questions in
I'll stop you right there anyone who
tells you that you shouldn't or you
can't ask theological questions that's
someone that you should just disregard
I've just utterly disregard them people
who say that are I really detest that
actually you absolutely should be asking
questions we're not a cult for goodness
sakes right we're not a cult
that's what cults do culture and say
don't ask questions just accept it that
were not that and if you go to a church
where that's the attitude then that is a
cult Church and you should find another
one that's my opinion she continues in
my soul I felt Calvinism was
inconsistent with what I knew to be true
about the loving nature of God and the
Bible only to be shamed for feeling that
way in the first place in the past few
weeks I've found some non Calvinist
interpretations of Scripture which have
only brought up more questions so I will
continue to seek answers potentially for
the rest of my life life but my question
to you is you obviously reject Calvinism
and I would assume the entire tulip
system how did you come to that
conclusion not only philosophically but
according to Scripture how do you or
rather how does the Catholic Church
contend with seemingly Calvinistic
passages such as Roman mind alright well
you know Kirsten I think I called you
Cristen before sorry for me it's not
about one passage or another you could
always quote mine
you can always cherry pick you can
always proof text meaning you can go
into scripture with a conclusion already
in mind and find passages that will
support that conclusion you can always
do that and you can
do that with anything you couldn't prove
quote-unquote prove any conclusion you
want about anything if that's how you're
approaching the Bible because the Bible
is a very big book with a lot with a lot
of books inside it and a lot of words a
lot of sentences a lot of verses a lot
of chapters and if you don't care about
context and you're just looking to
support the doctrine you already had in
mind before you approach scripture then
you'll be able to do it if you want to
prove that Jesus was a created being and
not God you can do that by proof texting
and in fact heretical sects have done
that since the very early days of
Christianity and and and I think in fact
they have more out of context verses
then that they can quote to support
their conclusions then do a lot of a lot
of other Christians with with their own
erroneous conclusions so well I mean
like for instance I mean there's so many
but you Jesus says talks frequently
about various points about how God is
greater than he says he says when he is
called good he says why do you call me
good there's only you know there's only
God the Father is good paraphrasing a
little bit that verse among several
others was one that that the Aryans and
others pointed to to say that well
clearly God is is not equal to the
Father it's it clearly Jesus is not
equal to the Father which if you're just
looking at that passage alone by itself
with nothing else then sure maybe it
does indicate that but once you take a a
total view of Scripture you start to see
how a row Gnaeus that conclusion would
be here's what I'll say then taking a
total view of Scripture if everything is
predetermined if we are consigned to
hell or granted heaven regardless of our
choices if some of if some of us are
literally created to be damned and we
have no choice we have no will we have
no say in it
that would render the entire Bible moot
the entire Bible is poisonous I don't
even need to point to one verse the
entire thing hasn't serves no purpose in
that case if God is just pulling the
strings and it's and we have no say it
doesn't matter what we do what we
believe it just it's just it's it's all
determined from there are those of us
who are created from the very moment of
conception and we are on the path to
hell there's nothing we can do to change
it well then what's what the Bible
serves no function there's no reason for
it to exist what does the Bible contain
after all well it contains the story of
God's relationship to man the story of
salvation yes but it's not just that
it's not just a storybook it's not just
the kind of hey check out what happened
isn't this interesting kind of thing
there are also hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of pages worth of instruction
old and new Testament do this don't do
this live this way don't live that way I
don't need to quote one particular verse
if I have if you you know if if I need
to get in specifics let's start with the
Sermon on the Mount or the old or the
ten commandments start with just those
two for a minute
all of that stuff it only has meaning it
only has a point there is only a reason
to read it if we can actually choose to
follow it and if our choosing to follow
it will potentially have some positive
impact on our own lives and on the world
if we can't choose to follow it or if
choosing to follow it won't end won't
matter in the end didn't won't amount to
anything because it's all predestined
anyway then there's no point
I mean why read it why encourage anyone
else to read it why would you go to
someone and say yeah you should really
read the Bible when their ultimate
destination has already been determined
whether they read it or not doesn't
matter so that that's what I would say I
would say that it's not just that that
these doctrines of predetermination
predestination it's not just that they
undermine one verse or another it's that
they undermine the entire thing and
that's the
alright this is from mark dear Matt I am
a self how do I know that other people
ourselves how do I know that I'm not the
only person on earth and everyone else
is a robot or a hologram thank you this
is actually a really interesting
question I love this question I wish I
had left more time for it and you could
kind of tell if you're someone who's
interested in philosophy depending on
your reaction to a question like that if
you hear that question you just roll
your eyes and are bored already just by
the question itself then you're probably
then philosophy isn't for you me I find
that question to be fascinating because
it touches on an elemental truth of
human experience of human existence and
and that is this that we can only
experience our own lives we only know
what it's like to be ourselves we cannot
be anyone else yet every other person is
a person every other person is a self
their own self and this fact is actually
fascinating when you think about it now
to answer your question briefly from a
rigorous and technical philosophical
perspective I guess we have to say that
you don't technically know that anyone
else exists you know I mean it's from a
philosophically you I guess we have to
leave open the possibility that everyone
else is a robot or a mirage or something
but for all intents and purposes
measuring plausibility is here you can
operate with very strong confidence that
other people exist the chance that other
people exist is far greater than the
chance that you're the only person and
we are all figments but so that that's I
think how you answer that question but I
think there's more to be said because
the fact that we are all people that we
are all selves it is still mysterious
right it's still a truth that you can
only acknowledge but but but you don't
really tap into or experience for
yourself I mean the fact I mean I'm
talking to you right now and I am a
person I have my own internal life my
own perspective and I don't even know
who you are like new
even a part of it aside from the fact
that you wrote this email isn't that
interesting
have you ever been I assume that this
happens to other people but have you
ever been driving down the road and
you've got cars passing you by on the
other side of the road and suddenly this
thought occurs to you it occurs to you
that each of those cars contains people
and those people each of them are just
as unique and complex and interesting as
you that they have an internal life
that's as real and as vivid and as deep
and as complicated as your own each
person in each of those cars they have
their own story their own saga their own
history their own secrets their own
memories their own desires their own
goals their own flaws and virtues
they're all stars of their own story and
you are irrelevant to their story you
know they are all the most interesting
people in their own plotlines and you
play no role at all they don't even know
you exist you are nothing to them I mean
you could die tomorrow and they would
never know or care or realize to them
you're just a car passing on the highway
just like they are to you isn't it isn't
it crazy to think that that that you to
someone out to to to so many other
people on earth that is all you've ever
been to them you're just a guy in the
car and you're gone and that's it now I
think this thought when it occurs to you
this realization about the complexity of
other human beings especially about the
existence of their own internal life
their own internal monologue their own
consciousness this realization I think
can be disturbing disturbing because
when you think about it you kind of feel
your own existence start to sort of
dissolve into irrelevance when you
realize that almost everyone on earth
almost everyone who's ever existed on
earth has never heard of you will never
meet you never care about you almost
everything you've ever thought or felt
or experienced will die with you decay
into the ground nobody will ever know
about it if you have something that
you're really worried about some anxiety
that's eating you up it's taking up all
your mental energy well when you
that anxiety just exact evaporates that
thing that was so important to you so
central to the universe as you
experience it is nothing to everybody
else absolutely nothing I think that's
the disturbing part but if you think
about a different way it's also
comforting because you realize that
you're actually not alone in the world
you aren't in fact the only vividly
drawn portrait in a world full of stick
stick figures you aren't the only person
in a world full of robots or Holograms
you're not alone you've got seven
billion other people sharing the burden
of existence with you and and those
anxieties that you care so much about
well maybe the fact that to everybody
else they're nothing or you know maybe
that's a good thing to know that
everything you're worried about really
isn't that big of a deal in the grand
scheme a billion other people have
worried about those same things probably
it's old hat it's routine whatever it is
maybe that's comforting and I think the
main thing is just to know that that
you're not alone I honestly think that
every problem in our society could be
solved every single problem at least all
of our interpersonal problems conflicts
and strife and all of that all of it
could be solved if you could just that
moment assuming you have those moments
to on the highway if you could just
capture that moment and and live in that
moment and live with that mind set if we
could all do that all the time all our
problems go away I think we really would
live in a utopia in that case because I
think all of our conflict in the end
stems from our inability or our
unwillingness to recognize the selfhood
of others I mean it's easy to recognize
that other people are people although a
lot of people in our society struggle
even with that especially as it pertains
to the unborn but even if you recognize
intellectually that people are people
that's not the same as recognizing that
they ourselves that they that they are a
self like you I think if you could keep
that at the forefront of your mind if we
all could all the time we would live at
peace and harmony but
we can't and we can't live that way
nobody ever know but no one lives that
way all the time certainly there's never
gonna be a time when everybody lives
that way all the time
so I think the best we could hope to do
is just is just be intentional in our
thinking and as much as possible bring
our minds back to that reality that
every other person is a self just like
the US they have their own existence
their own perspective their own internal
monologue their own life right doesn't
make doesn't mean that you know everyone
is it doesn't mean that they're right
about everything is that's not the point
it's just that they they had that they
are far more complex than you probably
think
especially I think if we could just
bring this thought to our minds in
situations where we going back to the
car like you're in the car you're
sitting in traffic you're you know
you're you're angry there's a thousand
other cars on the road they're all in
your way your anger be think about being
angry in traffic we all have but I know
I am all the time
think about how absurdly selfish and
stupid that is the reason why there's
traffic is that there's a bunch of other
people on the road trying to go the same
direction as you and they have just as
much a right to go that way as you do
and if you just stop for a minute and
and look at your own thought which is
okay I am I am being angry about traffic
and then if you could just try to put
that thought to the side and then
realize it all these other cars have
people in them and and and and to those
people you are just a car in their way
if you could just and not only that but
as far as traffic goes there's a good
chance that the traffic jam is happening
because somebody got into an accident
and so for you the worst that happens is
you're 25 minutes late minutes late to
dinner meanwhile somebody might have
just died or their whole life might have
been turned upside down by a serious
injury and here you are in your
self-obsessed little little tiny world
and all you care about is that you're
gonna be late to this thing that doesn't
even matter so if we could just
yeah that's my that's my that's my
little self-help sermon for the day but
I do think that I don't know there's
something there I mean the moment you
can start thinking even if it's just for
a moment but I what I found is that if I
can force myself to think this way in
moments I it immediately makes me less
and less angry less stressed out and I
in that moment at least I'm just a
happier person so if we could recall
that more and more I think that would be
to our benefit all right we will leave
it there thanks everybody for watching
thank you for listening
Godspeed hey everyone its Andrew Clavin
host of the Andrew Clavin show Robert
Muller is testifying before the House
Judiciary Committee today and earlier
this morning a Volkswagen pulled into
the Capitol Rotunda and onlookers
watched with delight and wonder as all
235 congressional Democrats poured out
of the car until committee chairman
Jerry Nadler finally emerged wearing a
baggy polkadot outfit gigantic shoes
white makeup and a fright wig and
announced to reporters that he did not
want the hearing to turn into some kind
of circus we'll talk about it on the
Andrew Clavin show
I'm Andrew Clavin